now that we know a little bit about
lists i thought i would use this video
to introduce you to loops and in
particular for loops and if we have time
we might do other types of loops but
before we even do that i want to
introduce you to a built-in python
function called range when i say
built-in means it comes with python and
it's really a way to generate lists
lists that have integers that increment
so for example if i just say
range of 6
it makes a list it generates a list from
zero through five so it's six elements
up to but not including six if i wanted
to include six i would have to do range
of seven
and then i go all the way up to but not
including seven but i get 6 in there if
i want to have 1 through 6 if i don't
want to have that 0 there i could do z
range
starting at 1 and including 1 up 2 but
not including 7. so the first item here
will be included the last item will not
be included
and then we get there we go we get one
two three four five six and what's cool
about these integrated development
environments these ides this pi scripter
that i'm running is that when i type in
a function
that it recognizes it actually will tell
me a little bit something about that
function in case you forget it so i
don't know if you can read this here but
it says range start stop step so you can
also you can also if you want tell it
how much to in so right now the default
is to increment by one each time but it
says hey i could tell you to increment
by a different number so let's say you
have a range say you start at zero
zero you want to go up to and
up to
eight
and i wanna go up by two instead of one
so then i went zero two four six and i i
should have said it more precisely up
two but not including eight the upper
part of the range you don't include it
so it goes up to that and it increments
it by two so you could do it like that
or you could even so maybe you want to
start at maybe you want to start at
three
and you want to go up two but not
including i don't know let me do up two
but not including 31 and you want to go
up by steps of three
so there you go they went up to step by
three up two but not including 31 so it
can generate a whole bunch of lists and
the reason why this is useful is because
we can use these inside of loops
and so the first type of loop i'm going
to introduce you to is a for loop so
this was the interpreter down here here
i'm going to actually write a program
so this program is really just to show
you what a for loop does so i could say
i and i is this variable that's often
used in for loops in iterative loops and
iterative means you keep doing something
over and over again 4i in and let me
just do a simple one in range and i'm
just going to say 5 range of 5. so this
will generate a list zero one two three
four so four i in range five and this
colon says now let's we're gonna have a
sub clause of what to do on each of
those iterations let's just print out
let's just print what out what i is and
so before we even see what this is going
to do let's just think about it it's
saying for
set each time we go through this loop
for each for each of the things for each
of the things in the range make i refer
to them and then each of those loops is
going to refer to a different one and
you want to print it out so let's just
try this out so let me save this program
and now let me run it
so there you go what it did is it
created a loop so it each time it goes
to the loop it assigns i to a different
element in this list as you remember
this list was zero one two three and
four and so did i say zero one two three
four five and before no zero one two
three four up two but not including five
and so each time you go through the loop
i is it goes it goes through each of
those items and this program just really
just says print out that i so the first
time i go to loop i is zero so it prints
it out then it prints out one then it
prints a two then it prints at three
then it prints a four so it just keeps
going through it that many times if we
said this was four range i don't know
10. now let's run this program you'll
see it'll print
one through nine
it'll print one through nine if you or i
should say zero through nine because
that's the first element in this list
but you could do more interesting things
let's say that you wanted let's say you
wanted to take the sum of 0 through 9.
so what you could do is you could define
another variable here sum so before i do
anything the sum is just going to be
zero
and then what you could say is each time
you go through the loop each time you go
through a loop why don't you add to sum
why don't you define sum to be the
previous sum plus
plus what i is in this part of the loop
and just so that we can keep track of it
i then want to print
i then want to print the sum i then want
to print the sum now let's see what this
thing does so let's try it out so let me
save it
and then let me
let me run it so there you go each time
we went through the loop so the first
time we went to the loop sum is zero sum
is zero and i zero you add them together
you print the sum you get zero the next
time we go to loop i is one we add that
to the previous sum which was zero print
it you get one then the next time
through the loop i is now going to be
two add that to the previous sum two
plus one you get three next time through
the loop i is 3 add that to the previous
sum you get 6. so the sum of all of the
numbers 0 through 9 is 45. so just that
that's actually a kind of a useful kind
of a useful program but just to make the
point a little bit clearer let me
actually let me actually
walk you through this
on my little drawing tablet
so let me close my let me paste it
let me paste my code that i just wrote
up here and let's just think about what
this let's just think about what this is
doing
so we have a couple of variables here we
start off with this variable sum we
start off with this variable sum that is
set to zero
so sum and there's two ways to visualize
variables a common way to visualize it
and this isn't necessarily wrong this is
sometimes an easier way to think about
it is to view them as buckets but in
python the really correct way and you
saw why that's important with lists is
to view them as referring to something
so if you view them as buckets you can
kind of say okay from the get go the the
number in the sum bucket is zero but the
reality is is that the variable sum
is now referring to
the the numeric literal the actual
number zero sitting in memory someplace
now we enter into the for loop and what
the for loop says is let's assign let's
itera iteratively assign i to each of
the elements in the list generated by
range of 10. so just to be clear
if we call this right over here range of
10 this will generate a list that looks
like this
so it will generate a list of 0
1 2
3 4 5 6 7
and 9. up to but not including 10 this
is 10 elements right over here
and then we go into the for loop so the
first time we go through the for loop
and let me write it so i'll do it i'll
think about it two different ways
so i want to think about it in the
bucket way
i'll think about it the bucket way so we
have this variable i that can actually
only be used inside of this clause we'll
talk about more about scope or where
where a variable could use but this i
variable is only good inside of this
clause the sum variable the way i've
defined it i can use it anywhere outside
of the clause or inside of it because it
was defined outside of the clause
so your i so this is if you think of it
as a bucket and so the first through the
first iteration i is assigned to this
first item over here so i is going to be
0. the reality the better way to think
about it is i is actually referring to
this first element our first time
through the loop and then we go through
the loop and it says sum plus i well sum
is zero and i is zero you add them
together you get zero so sum is still
going to be zero or still referring to
zero and then it prints the sum out so
then this line right over here
this line over here it prints sum it
says okay the sum right now is just it's
just let me do it in blue it's just 0
and it printed it out then it goes back
to the for loop and says look are there
any more elements that i can assign i to
well sure there are there's all of these
that we have to go through so then it
makes i the next element in the sequence
so now i is going to be the next element
in the sequence or another way to think
about it is in the i bucket if you want
to view them as buckets
i is now set equal to one and now we run
this again and we say okay sum is 0 plus
i i is 1. so sum is now going to refer
to 1. so sum
is now going to refer to 1 or another
way to think about it is sum is now
going to refer to one and when you print
some
it'll now print one
then it'll go the for loop will say all
right can are there any more elements in
this list right over here to to assign i
to well sure there are there's all of
these others so let me keep going
so i can now be
i can now be equal to or can refer to 2.
so if you think of it as a bucket i is
now 2 or you say i is now referring to 2
and you can ignore these right over here
and we go through the loop again sum is
now 1 1 plus i i is now 2 1 plus 2 is 3.
so sum is now going to be 3 this time
through the loop
so
sum is now referring to three you print
sum you get three and you keep going all
the way i is going to keep referring to
as we go through the loop the loop will
still keep going as there's more things
that i can uh that i can refer to as if
we can keep incrementing i to these
other values over here and eventually i
is going to be 9 we're going to evaluate
this and the for loop says hey is there
anything left in this list that i can be
and you're like no there isn't anything
left in this list and then the loop is
going to be done and we'll break out to
it and the program will stop and that's
exactly what we saw happening that's
exactly what we saw happening when we
ran the program over here